pierre c'est un très grand sportif non
non c'est pas une vanne non non c'est
vrai c'est ta meilleure van non non non
voici mon stagiaire Tom villa
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi ça je ne veux pas travailler
c'est quoi c'est un message chérie
est-ce que tout le monde peut poser des
RTT tout le monde peut partir en weekend
j'ai pas de weekend voilà donc stagiaire
c'est 0 vacances
Nabila aymeric Caron pierre Ménez c'est
le top 3 du classement des gens les plus
détestés de France voilà il manque plus
que Dieudonné et François Hollande et on
était au fond non heureusement il y a
MHD petite pépite il y aura qui
MHD le créateur de l'afro trap l'afro
trap c'est un mélange de musique afro et
de rap français voilà c'est un peu comme
les Magic System mais avec des papiers
alors votre nom de scène MHD vient de
votre prénom moi Ahmed et vous avez
gardé les consonnes et ça donne MHD très
très bonne idée parce que si vous aviez
gardé les voyelles ça donnait et là ça
faisait plus ça faisait plus handicapé
que rappeur
notre expert a quel âge le foot quand
même en plus en plus Pierre il est il
est trilingue français anglais Ribéry
c'est très fort
ça c'est ce que j'aime bien c'est j'ai
regardé en disant il s'est clasher plus
de fois que Georges Marchais dans toute
sa vie il cache tout le monde les
joueurs les entraîneurs les dirigeants
chaque si la Fatou existé dans le foot
tu serais mort
pierre c'est un très grand sportif non
non c'est pas une vanne non non c'est
vrai c'est ta meilleure vanne non non
non
c'est pas
tu joues super bien au foot on sauve
qu'avec pierre un petit pont on appelle
ça l'Arc de Triomphe
Nabilla Nabilla je préfère voilà vous
prévenir il y a des détecteurs de métaux
à l'entrée du studio mais c'est pas
contre vous c'est à cause du plan
Vigipirate nous on y est pour rien c'est
bon on va en parler comme ça on sera
débarrassé oui il y a eu cette fameuse
nuit du 6 novembre oui il y a eu un coup
de couteau mais voilà vous avez dit s'il
y avait une louche j'aurais pris une
louche
ah c'est ballot parce que ça aurait pas
fini en prison mais un Top Chef donc ça
c'est quand même
[Applaudissements]
la Villa beaucoup de gens prennent pour
une idiote et franchement moi je suis
pas je suis pas d'accord parce que vous
avez quand même écrit deux livres et
écrire deux livres quand on en a lu
qu'un seul c'est quand même vachement
bien
et juste pour terminer ça c'est pas une
vanne en fait je cherche des auteurs
parce que quand même Nabilla qu'on l'a
vu je lui ai dit qu'elle était écrouée à
Versailles elle a répondu quoi au
château de Versailles
je peux pas faire le
[Applaudissements]
la proposition est ouverte
Thierry ce soir c'est la soirée des
auteurs Nabilla et Mike Caron est chez
pivot là c'est Pierre si tu as fait la
préface de l'album Panini pour l'Euro tu
nous le dis il y a pas de
Aymeric sachant que vous défendez les
animaux on a fait très très attention ce
soir j'ai laissé ma veste en cuir chez
moi et Thierry a pas mis son slip
léopard donc ça c'est ça quand même
Caron l'année dernière vous aviez
participé à Fort Boyard voilà alors
qu'on met le traite les animaux ça vous
dérange par contre qu'on fasse courir
des kilomètres et des kilomètres des
nains sans les autoriser à parler ça
vous vous en foutez complètement
Aymeric il est tellement végétalien
qu'il a retiré de son vocabulaire les
expressions et mon cul c'est du poulet
et ah tu aimes ça [ __ ] voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs je me suis pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas à clasher les joueurs de
foot de manière très violente aussi sur
Twitter si il savait lire ou seriez
aussi virulent
et moi Caron en tant que vegetalien
qu'est-ce qui vous choque le plus de
voir un poulet se faire égorger dans un
abattoir ou une carotte utilisée dans
comme sextoys dans un porno
le premier le poulet MHD MHD pour pour
vous c'est important que les gens
retiennent vos paroles mais aussi vos
chorégraphies de sur vos chansons
de faire la Macarena sans déconner
et pour terminer Nabilla Nabilla en 2011
alors vous étiez hôtesse sur le stand de
Peugeot vous aviez été élu Miss Auto
Salon voilà d'après vous c'est grâce à
vos pare-chocs ou à votre intérieur
cuillère
dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu